Since Android Wear devices
are worn by the users,
they're the ideal platform to
implement fitness applications.
These types of applications
typically use sensors on the device
to measure step counts,
acceleration, and position.
The good news is that Android Wear
uses exactly the same sensor API
as regular Android phones and
tablet's, so
you can use all your existing
knowledge about sensors here as well.
Let's look at a sample
to see how it works.
A good one is called jumping jack.
So let's create a project
around that and test it.
In this case, I'm going to use
a real watch to test it out and
show you how it works.
Right now, it has zero on
the counter shown in the activity.
So let's do a few jumping jacks.
One, two, three and now, you can see
that it's counted the values correctly.
So what is different about working
with sensors on Android Wear?
Well, the main differences come
down to saving battery power, and
not doing too much processing
on the wearable device.
Let's go through some best practices for
sensors on Android Wear.
You want to do as little
work as possible.
So unregister your listener
when you don't need it.
For a running app,
we only want to log steps when the user
is running the actual activity.
For the rest of the day when the
activity is not running, we should put
the device to sleep and use
the standard watch face saving power.
The next things is to select
an appropriate update rate.
If you're going to refresh
the display every minute,
then there's no point getting
updates ten times per second.
And you might also want to request
that the results are batched up
over this time period, so that the CPU
can stay asleep the whole time.
The registerListener method allows
you to control these factors.
Also, make sure if you
need to process the data,
try to do as much on
the phone as possible.
Remember, the phone has a huge battery
compared to the little wearable here.
So take advantage of that.
If you're trying to measure
the bumpiness of a car ride, and
you know the Wearable user has
their phone with them, why not use
the accelerometer on the phone to do
the logging instead of the Wearable?
The GPS feature in Android Wear
does exactly this.
If you have the phone and
the Wearable in close proximity, it
will actually use the phone's GPS unit.
If the wearable goes out on a run
while the phone stays at home and
if the device has a GPS built in,
it'll use the GPS from the wearable.
There's a sample for
this called speed tracker.
Check it out for yourself and
see how it's implemented.
When you sensor that was
introduced in KitKat phones and
available on all Wearables
is the step counter.
This is really useful for
fitness applications and
is a low power sensor you can use often.
It's also a lot more efficient than
trying to build your own step counter by
reading the accelerometers.
The Android step counter is
provided by dedicated hardware.
You'll notice in the documentation
there is a TYPE_STEP_DETECTOR,
and a TYPE_STEP_COUNTER.
The detector is configured to trigger
every time a step is made, but
it's possible that you'll not receive
the events if the device is sleeping.
You also don't want to have
the device wake up and
run your code after every single step,
like at these points here.
Especially if you only refresh
the display every minute.
So the step counter here
is a much better idea.
It gives you an absolute value, so
your code does not need
to wake up on every step.
And you cannot miss any steps,
because you always get
the absolute value each time.